Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
Ruffians!
Good morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Are you good, Moco-chan?
I think... Maybe there's a frog living in my throat.
Well today, Ruffians, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 118th episode!
BAU BAU!
Any new Ruffians today?
Let us explain exactly what FUWAMOCO Morning is.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
A brand new morning.
It's the middle of the week.
The end of the week.
How is it the middle of the week?
Time just goes by so fast, Ruffians!
But you've already made it this far!
But it's just not that much further off, you know.
And there's lots of fun stuff, huh?
It's the end of the week, you know.
Not quite Friday, though.
But!
Well, we're still gonna have a bunch of fun this week, right, Ruffians?
Even before the weekend.
But, uh...
Huh?
There's been some bad news.
Tell me Moco-chan, what's the bad news?
There's been a Pero Sighting.
Why?
I don't know!
It was kind of concerning.
A little bit weird when there was no Pero Sightings.
But... Well, let's see!
Okay, let's take a look.
Where was Pero spotted?
De-den!
Is Pero allowed to be doing that, Ruffians?
A balloon!
You know, he is big and all muscle and everything, but I don't think it's okay for him to be such an important air balloon, you know?
In an event like this, the Olympics, you know?
Ruffians!
Do you approve of this?
Do you think this is a good idea?
You think the little wings?
I don't think the little wings are doing anything.
I don't know.
Would you ride on the Pero balloon?
I'll give you a needle.
No, no.
It trusts you.
You were right!
It is good that he's doing something maybe to help out.
Is this helping out?
It's doing something, right?
Something.
Not too sure what it is, but... Transportation?
Transportation!
But... I don't know.
I don't think... You try it at least once.
I don't think a pin will work.
I think, you know, we should just shoot him out of the sky.
What?! !
Well... Wait, what if he spots Pudding?
We don't know!
We should neutralize it.
Like the birds!
No, the birds are better than Pero.
The birds in New York City... But this isn't in New York City, Moco-chan.
I don't see any birds, it could be New York City.
That's because I probably was scared off by Pero.
Okay, decision made, we shoot him out of the sky.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, all you're thinking about is New York right now because of Breaking Dimensions?
No!
I'm thinking of something else!
Oh!
Like what?
You might have seen Ruffians, but we had...
A new song!
You think it's a Breaking Dimensions, huh?
Y'all Ruffians!
A new song?
A new song for hololive English just came out!
Did you see?
Guess what?
It's Breaking Dimensions!
Yes, that's the title!
Who could've guessed?
The lyrics are so nice, right?
So emotional!
You know, it's generally known as Hashtag First Promise.
Hashtag First... Advent!
I don't know.
Maybe it's just because we're Advent.
But I really feel like everything comes together once we join them in the end of the song.
Right?
I like Nerissa's part.
Yeah.
Let's rebel!
And Biboo!
Biboo!
It's very cute.
Not too surprising.
I really think of the choreography, Ruffians.
It's very cute, but uh...
I wasn't very good at the body rolls.
Since the body rolls... I can't do them very well, Ruffians.
But I'll do my best!
You thought it was good?
It's kind of funny.
I'm doing my best, okay?
But... Well...
Ruffians, maybe one day in the future someday we'll get to perform it for you.
Maybe one day.
I'm sure that day will come.
Eventually.
There's a lot of days!
Yeah, but please listen to it a lot!
I like it because it's quite different from countries around the world.
Right, it's sort of a cool feeling.
Yeah.
Like, cooling.
Not like cool, like wow, cool, but like refreshing.
Like a, what's it, an ice cone.
An ice cone!
Like an ice cone, like a, what's it, an ice cone.
A snow cone, like that.
Like an ice cone.
Are you like that it was in English?
Why are the lyrics in English?
Connect the World is also in English, so please check it out too!
But the lyrics you know about me, you can kind of be able to connect more deeply with it maybe.
And especially you know if you don't speak Japanese.
Make sure you get your streaming tickets!
You can get your streaming tickets for Breaking Dimensions, a two-day concert over on SPWN on Spawn or E+, so please go check out the Breaking Dimensions website.
Especially if you want to see more FUWAMOCO on the big stage, more Advent on the big stage, this is the number one thing you can do to make that happen!
Okay, Ruffians?
Please check it out, okay?
BAU BAU!
I'm so excited, breaking the legend is like here.
It's almost now.
It's like next week.
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
Well, also very soon, we have
Yo!
FUWAMOCO!
Our unofficial world tour continues because very shortly this weekend we're gonna be performing in Seoul at PopCon!
Yeah!
In Korea!
FUWAMOCO!
We're so, so excited!
I'm a little nervous too!
I'm not facial because it just happened.
Yeah, we've had such a lucky opportunity to go to so many different places across the world and see lots of different Ruffians and BAU BAU together!
And this time, this is our next, our next, our next stop!
Yeah!
We're so excited to be able to meet some
Korean skills are not very good.
I think our Australian was better.
And that says a lot, right Moco-chan?
But it's okay because we're fans!
We'll definitely go BAU BAU lots together, right?
BAU BAU just sends anything, right?
But at BAU BAU we're gonna be doing a mini Rock n' Rawr Party!
Maybe we'll be singing some songs we don't usually often sing.
We're also gonna be doing a meet-and-greet too!
So Inori gets to meet some BAUFUS up close!
BAU BAU!
That's it.
On the topic of being nervous.
Well yesterday, Ruffians, we had a really big collab together with
With AZKi-senpai and Akuma-senpai!
It still feels like a dream, right Moco-chan?
I woke up and I felt funny.
That happened!
You and them!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, we had so much fun and we are so honored.
I felt like we were able to say that a lot to both AZKi-senpai and Akoe-senpai.
But I feel like we still didn't say enough of how happy.
Right, I felt like you made me funny, huh.
Yeah, it was so much fun and it really meant so much to us too because it was our first ever and also last collab with Aqua-senpai.
And we had so much fun singing all together.
Aqua-senpai and AZKi-senpai.
We saw a bunch of internet oldies together.
Let's go Omiyagi.
We had Yukai.
Lots of fun stuff and you know some emotional songs too.
Emotional rollercoaster.
Yeah.
It was really fun, but we were just so happy to be invited by AZKi-senpai because, you know, we were surprised to hear Aqua-senpai know that she's gonna be graduating.
And we really wanted to be able to do something together with her!
Yeah!
And you know, right when we were sort of like,
What should we do?
And AZKi-senpai messaged us!
We're so thankful.
So happy!
But we were a bit surprised to hear that the reason Aqua-senpai ended up agreeing.
Yeah, at first when we knew AZKi-senpai was like, I wanna do a karaoke together with Aqua-senpai, she was like, no.
I don't want to do one-on-one, you know?
But then she ended up agreeing because AZKi-senpai said that we would do it a lot!
FUWAMOCO would be there too!
Yeah!
So we were really surprised!
We were like, did I just hear that right?
Yeah, Akari-senpai said that she wanted to collab with us before, but...
You know, Aqua-senpai is very shy.
FUWAMOCO, we're really shy!
Yeah, sure!
We're so... You know, we wanna be able to clap more and more with our senpai, but it's always kinda hard, you know?
We're just the noobies, the underdogs.
We do have kouhai now, but we're still the underdog noobies, so... Yeah, we wanna prove ourselves.
Yeah, you know.
Yeah, Aqua-senpai's really, really shy, right?
But we're so happy.
Yeah!
And it was a really fun collab too!
And I know when we were singing the emotional songs together too, we kinda wrote some letters for Aqua-senpai.
And I always made her cry.
We were really shocked!
You know?
I don't know.
I'm confused.
This is our first time together.
Oh no!
What do we do, Moco-chan?
We're really happy.
We know that our feelings got to Aqua-senpai and she received them, you know.
And you know, both AZKi-senpai and Aqua-senpai, they were able to sing Fake Fake Fake together!
Yeah, you know, Fake Fake Fake is one of AZKi-senpai's really early songs where Aqua-senpai is like the main part of her MV.
She's like the star.
The star of the MV.
And that was the first time that they ever sang it together.
Sang it?
The other day with AZKi-chan.
And you know, we also got to sing Akoa-senpai's song Kaesou Deshou together too.
That's one of my favorite FUWAMOCO songs.
Yeah, we were able to request it!
I felt a little bit bad, like AZKi-senpai, we wanna sing this song!
We were invited, but we wanna sing this song!
Making requests, right!
What are these demon dogs doing?
We're so happy we were able to have the time.
Both of us!
Not just Fuwawa!
I was so nervous that one.
But also Ruffians!
Aisuke-senpai and Aqua-senpai!
They have a brand new cover song coming out tomorrow morning of I'm My Moco.
So please go check it out on Aisuke-senpai's channel too!
And for Ruffians who weren't able to watch the karaoke collab too, it is archived on Aisuke-senpai's channel.
It's very confusing.
It has nothing to do with Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Thank you again, Aki-senpai!
Thank you, Ako-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Fuwawa is related to Moco-chan, that is true.
I am related.
Moco-chan is related to Fuwawa, yes.
Unrelated.
Ruffian.
I don't know if you've seen this.
It was just just released, but we appeared in a very silly story on the hololive YouTube channel!
On the main channel!
Together with Noe-chan!
Did you see it?
It's still very new!
Very new!
Fresh!
Yeah, it was really silly, but it was really silly!
Yeah, we are totally no FUWAMOCO, please be really extra silly!
Since this time it's a bit more of a comedy skit, the first time we've ever kind of done this.
It was indeed very silly.
I know Nerissa-senpai, she's being very kind, teaching us all about Japan.
You know, since we're exchange students, we just came to Japan.
But, we kind of think she talks too much.
It's very silly!
And you know, the punchline is that our actual thoughts are very, very rude!
And it's something that we never really say.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO We really like Japanese comedies, so we're really curious about trying more of these kind of things too.
So, hopefully...
Maybe we can be a little bit more silly together with my senpai too.
Yeah.
Comedian idols.
BAU BAU.
I don't know.
We're FUWAMOCO!
I don't think we're very funny, but maybe we'll be funny one day.
We're silly.
BAU BAU!
Nobunaga-senpai's voice is so cute.
FUWAMOCO's Summer Memories.
Together with you!
I'm sure Ruffians, you know, it's one of the things on the holosummer bingo, in case you didn't know, so, we're getting it completed now!
You know, Ruffians, I'm sure you're the same as you, little puppy, but with FUWAMOCO we're puppies!
One of my favorite things in the summertime is to play outside!
Outside of our home in the Northwest Passage, and you know, like we shared with you, we have the big stream,
Yeah, the river!
I always like to play in it.
And there'd be these, like, bugs.
Yeah, like water bugs.
Maybe these things floating on the water and you try to catch them, but then... I don't know, they're always really scary.
Run away.
You catch them and then they run away.
I don't know.
But you catch them too and then it's not very fun.
It's fun to see them on the water.
Right?
Yeah, they can go on the ground too.
But then it's just the one one.
So we play with those, we play in the water and splash and stuff.
And you know when we get popsicles from Mama Puppy?
Yeah!
Popsicles!
I remember going on like a blanket on the run.
Yeah.
And you know, then we have them, but there'd be like a little green bug.
I smell like a grasshopper.
No, but they hop around.
Yeah.
They look friendly.
So I remember watching them having popsicles.
Yeah.
And Mama Puppy would make the popsicles too!
Yeah, I really want the orange flavored ones right now.
I like the purple ones.
The purple ones.
Yeah.
Then sometimes, you know, demon dogs, we like to BAU BAU.
Sometimes I hear like other puppies kind of far away in the distance going BAU BAU!
So then we'll be like BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
The voice tweet.
Maybe for the younger Ruffians out there.
Kinda like that.
You don't know who's gonna receive it, but it's out there.
Like that.
It's very exciting.
Like talking.
No, you're not talking!
You don't know who's gonna hear it.
And you don't know who responds.
Right, they might BAU BAU back at you.
You only hear the BAU BAU.
So it's very exciting.
Kinda like you're like...
Oh, I don't know what's gonna happen from here on out, but at most you're probably just gonna get a bump bump back.
Yeah.
Did you eat grasshoppers?
No!
It's fun to watch them.
Yeah, maybe you catch them.
But you know if you're eating a popsicle, the popsicle's gonna be good.
Then you don't need to eat a grasshopper, you have the popsicle.
Yeah, you know.
Ruffians, why you don't eat this?
Do we catch them?
Yeah.
Yeah, you catch them.
You have fun.
Fireflies are better!
I would like to see fireflies!
Moco-chan, do you remember throwing them at each other?
Yeah, just a lot of time spent outside enjoying the nature, you know?
Everything's so nice in the North Post.
The dandeboubous too!
Summertime is when the dandeboubous are in full force.
Yeah.
Hopefully Ruffians, maybe that made you remember some of your memories.
Some of my memories.
Or maybe it was completely new to you.
If it was, maybe you should go outside and try to do the same.
Maybe have some pupsicles.
Yeah.
Take a blanket on on the grass and look at the bugs.
If it's not too hot.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can't remember.
Where is Pero's house?
Doesn't matter.
No.
That's enough, FUWAMOCO!
Let's just solve our memories!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, we did a lot of silly fun things.
Just the two of us, right?
Just silly stuff.
Yeah.
But Ruffians!
It's the middle of the week!
You've been doing your best.
How is it going?
How is it the middle of the week, huh?
Is a bit a little bit rough?
Maybe Moco-chan, you have some head pads for the Ruffians?
A bit rough.
Ruffians!
You did it!
It's the middle of the week, and it's time that you to listen up.
That you are going to listen up!
Because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians.
Have you been trying something new recently?
Maybe it's been a bit tricky for you?
Maybe I left feeling sort of like I used to be able to pick up things so quickly!
What happened?
And you know what?
That's okay!
Sometimes it just takes us more time than we're used to to learn new things.
And just the fact that you're trying something outside of your comfort zone that you wouldn't usually do is amazing!
And to be honest, at first, it probably won't go well.
And that's fine!
You'll slowly but surely gain more experience and get more skilled, okay?
You don't need to rush!
Remember, the journey is what's most important.
Know how quickly you get to the end result that you want, okay?
Let's keep doing our best together!
Ganbatte desu!
BAU BAU!
Got it!
FUWAMOCO will continue to try new things too.
Like harmony.
I am.
Let's do our best, FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Let's check out who's the Doggie of the Day today.
Our Doggie of the Day is...
Sam!
And Olive!
So cute!
Such beautiful eyes!
Did you feel a little bit confused there?
Which doggy is the Doggie of the Day here?
Plenty of it confused!
Yeah!
Together with the Ruffians!
You know, Olive's obviously very friendly!
Just curling up close together with the Ruffians there!
Right?
A bit envious, huh?
Moco-chan, you feel envious!
I like to hang out with the Ruffians like this too.
It does look very confident, right?
Yeah.
You thought it was about the Ruffians!
Ruffians do the Doggie of the Day every day!
Got it.
Well, I'm so happy that all of us can make some new friends here!
Jr.
3D Watch Party.
BAU BAU!
How does all of BAU BAU Moco-chan?
That's not what I was asking.
Moco-chan!
FUWAMOCO!
You know, Olive is just such a sweet doggie.
Very patient.
Loves to make friends.
And you know, I think she also really enjoys, you know, sharing the things that you're very passionate about together with you.
Because she loves you!
She wants to have fun together with you.
You enjoy your favorite things.
She loves your favorite things!
She loves you.
BAU BAU!
And next, for our walk of the day, we have... That one's called Moco-chan.
The day I went on a walk.
BAU BAU, where did we go?
Ruffians!
Dance!
No!
That wasn't today!
That was a little while ago, Moco-chan!
Hi!
You're gonna break my heart!
BAU BAU!
Deh!
No.
Hi!
Deh!
BAU BAU!
I was about to say to the Ruffians.
Ruffians, did you not go on a walk this time?
Got lost on the walk.
BAU BAU!
I'm so glad that you had such a nice walk together with the Ruffians.
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
Going to Akiba MisDo at the end of your walk is one thing, but just you know, the best walks I find are ones together with friends.
And ones that also have treats at the end.
Always.
But in FUWAMOCO, Akiba looks so nice.
Beautiful weather.
And you got pon-de-rings too!
Sometimes, more than often recently, they're sold out.
Extra lucky Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Secret land of the BAU BAU!
We see that there's even more Ruffians visiting Akiba recently and we're really happy!
BAU BAU!
And for the Question of the Day we have this!
De-den!
Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
Ako and Aisuke have been my GP Oshis for a long time!
So I was so happy to see my Kami Oshi FUWAMOCO sing together with them!
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy to be able to sit together with them.
Especially, you know, just being invited to such an amazing collab.
I could go on and on.
hololive I'm often called Aqua Inkyan.
My question is, do you consider yourself similar to her or are you more of a youkya?
Inkyan's more of like a...
More of a... Indoor person.
Introverted.
Introverted person.
You can more extra... Extraverted.
Extraverted.
That kind of thing.
Wait, Ruffians, what do you think?
Oh, oh.
Yes!
Which one?
Which one is FUWAMOCO?
Oh!
Oh?
I see lots of both.
Right.
Well, FUWAMOCO, we're definitely introverted.
We just do our best to appear extra morning.
I think Advent is also like that.
Advent is exactly the same.
Even Nerissa!
Even Nerissa, yeah.
But Nerissa's the one that's like, oh, ah, okay, you have to talk to somebody.
We all have to talk to somebody.
Okay, Nerissa, go!
I think it was funny because we were all at dinner the other day and I think...
Who was it?
Someone wanted another drink.
Nerissa wanted another drink.
And so she's like, FUWAMOCO, ask for another drink for me.
And we're like, no, I don't want to do that.
No, I don't want to.
I don't want to.
How are you doing?
Nerissa's like, you can speak Japanese, please ask.
And we're like, no, I don't want to do it, Moco-chan, you did it.
I did it before.
And then Biboo was just like, why?
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
We're all very introverted, but we do our best to be extroverted.
Sometimes we're better than others, and that's how it is!
Advent is all introverted.
Maybe a little bit of a different introvert compared to Aqua-senpai.
More or less, yeah.
Maybe this is also a reason why we all get along so well, huh?
Maybe?
You could tell when we said we couldn't buy the konbini chicken.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Mofius, for all your submissions!
Pero Sighting.
It'd be nice to get a Pero Sighting that makes us feel like... Yeah.
Right?
Right.
Every time it's like, Pero, no.
Right?
Right.
You know, more doggy of the days.
There's never a doggy that makes us go, rawr.
Right?
Please let us know what walks you've been going on.
Yeah!
I know I said last time but we've been getting some very good questions about things.
Walks you've been going on don't rocks.
No rocks.
Yeah.
Unless... Well...
Ruffians!
You know!
We have another stream coming up very soon!
And unfortunately there's a rock in it.
And next stream!
De-den!
We're having a karaoke off-camera with Biboo!
Yeah!
Diamond Dolls!
Very soon!
Unfortunately there's a rock in it.
Yeah.
Not just fluff and fuzz.
Fluff and fuzz on the rock.
It's a fun, a fun rock a lot.
We're gonna have fun together.
Maybe there might be some silliness that you'll have to catch.
I never know what's gonna happen together with the Diamond Dogs!
We definitely will be.
I don't know, maybe.
And speaking of collabs!
Wow, basically we have our Advent 3D collab!
On Saturday at 8pm PT, Advent will all be together for our very first 3D collab.
Look at that, Ruffians!
Don't miss it!
You can't miss it!
It's gonna be super fun!
Remind your friends, okay?
Yeah.
Almost forgot.
Yeah, but they know.
FUWAMOCO's here.
Here to remind you.
Yeah, yeah.
It's gonna be fantastic!
Will there be more violence?
You never know.
We'll have them.
Yummy taco pie!
Noice!
You'll have to be there to find us!
Yes!
Oppa!
Mama!
And my schedule!
Oh well!
FUWAMOCO we have our off club with Biboo.
But on Friday at 6pm PT, we're also gonna be having a Rock n' Rawr Party together with you Ruffians!
We also have the...
There's a lot going on, I can't talk about it all right now.
But on Rock n' Rawr Party, we're gonna be singing only hololive songs this time!
So please, you know, get warmed up before breaking the mentions.
And maybe sing along with us, get those penlights going!
We're really excited, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And then also, very early morning on Sunday at 3am PT, we'll be having an off collab together with Haachama-senpai!
Our first off collab together!
I'm very excited but a little nervous.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
You know we're playing Holococuna, a very scary game together with Haachama-senpai.
It's our first scary game off collab.
I don't know what if I was just...
Don't.
Don't poke me!
You say don't to me but... But Hachama- Hachama-senpai might... No.
Come up behind you.
She's coming.
Well, we'll see what happens!
And then we're also gonna be playing Aquarium later on Sunday evening.
So please join us!
Aquarium is Aqua-senpai's visual novel, so we're gonna enjoy it all together, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
And for Ruffians joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU bingo!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Wiggles!
BAU BAU!
Eames!
Pierre.
BAU BAU!
Cocoa.
Menmen.
BAU BAU!
Kisu.
Ah, Kisuro.
BAU BAU!
Dr. Crimson.
Ludoi.
BAU BAU!
Raincat.
Barbs.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!